تعمل المستشار العسكريه البريطانيه القاده
العسكريين الروس بالتخلي عن الوحدات
العسكريه وتبديد الموارد الاستراتيجيه
لتحقيق مكاسب تكتيكيه صغيره واوضح ان
روسيا تعاني من خسائر فادحه ادت لمقتل
واصابه ما يصل الى 30 الف عسكري روسي من
الجيش ومن قوات فاجنر في محيط باخموت
وحدها وذلك بمقابل التقدم لحوالي 25 كيلو
متر فقط وقالت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه ان
محاولات الجيش الروسي للسيطره على بلده
فوليزار بيدونيات تباطات بشكل كبير
الاسبوع الماضي بعد هجمات وصفتها بالفاشله
والمكلفه للغايه طيله ثلاثه اشهر واضافت
في تحليلها اليومي ان الدفاعات الاوكرانيه
في فوليدار تبنت بنجاح انظمه مضاده للدروع
اجبرت الجيش الروسي على سحب دباباته وسط
حاله من الفوضى واشارت الى ان الجيش
الروسي كان مصمما على دخول فوليدار
لمضاهات تقدم قوات فاجنر في باخموت في
اطار من التنافس بينهما